Sometimes Margot Robbie slaps people to get
her way, other times she just writes a nice
letter. This is the story of her journey
from Down Under to the top of the world.
Margot Robbie was born on July 2,
1990 on the gold coast of Australia,
the daughter of a sugarcane magnate. Her
father Doug left when she was very young,
resulting in a strained relationship
between the two, but she still has him
to thank for her upbringing on a rural farm
and for her education at private schools.
Despite having a rich father, Robbie and
her mom Sarie Kessler struggled to get by
after he left. Robbie picked up odd jobs
to make ends meet, including at the fast
food chain Subway. She was initially tasked
with slicing vegetables and cleaning cutlery,
but then she was promoted to the sandwich
line. As she recalled to Vanity Fair in 2014,
"I was really good at it! I make a
mean Subway. The trick is to spread
everything evenly out and cut it so
well that there is never a bad bite."
Robbie's other jobs included
catering, warehouse work,
and a stint at a pharmacy. Then after
she landed her first big acting gig
on an Australian soap opera, Subway
hired her to star in a commercial.
Fans outside Margot Robbie's home country
of Australia probably think of her mainly
as the avatar of American celebs Tonya
Harding or Sharon Tate. But back home,
she's perhaps even more beloved for her work
on the long-running soap opera Neighbors,
on which she played Donna Freedman. The
character became a fan favorite thanks in
part to positive bisexual representation
and Robbie's obvious star power.
Originally cast as a one-off role, Donna
soon became a recurring character. Robbie
ended up staying on the show for
three years, but then in 2010,
she left Australia to pursue a career
in Hollywood. As she told TV Week,
"I want to go to America; it's always
been my goal to work in Hollywood. It's
the one stage in my life where I have
absolutely nothing holding me down."
"Years living on Ramsay Street were honestly
some of the best of my entire life."
After Margott Robbie jetted off to Hollywood, she
initially landed a few small movie roles. And then
everything changed when director Martin Scorsese
cast her in the 2014 crime epic The Wolf of Wall
Street. She starred opposite Leonardo DiCaprio,
whose deranged energy she matched beat for beat.
Robbie reportedly got the part by slapping
DiCaprio in the face during her audition,
a move that was actually not in the original
script. As she recalled to Harper's Bazaar,
"In my head I was like, 'You have literally 30
seconds left in this room and if you don't do
something impressive nothing will ever come of it.
It's a once-in-a-lifetime chance, just take it.'"
And thus, that one slap set in motion a storied
career that has seen Robbie land
iconic role after iconic role.
When Robbie signed up for 2016's Suicide Squad,
she didn't know much about the character of Harley
Quinn. As she admitted to the Washington Post,
"I wasn't familiar with the comics.
I had vaguely heard of them,
but I had no idea that there was
such a big fanbase for Harley."
Nevertheless, her take on Harley was a hit, and
the character was even reportedly the most Googled
Halloween costume of 2016. It was a significant
departure from earlier versions of Harley, as her
outfit consisted of fishnets, a studded belt, and
a ripped tee shirt reading "Daddy's Lil Monster."
Though she initially had no plans to
play Harley again, Robbie leapt at the
opportunity to redeem the character with a
feminist spin in 2020's Birds of Prey. She
was also an executive producer this time
around. As she noted to Rotten Tomatoes:
"I thought the industry needed
a girl-gang action film."
Plenty of fans fell in love with Robbie's
version of Harley Quinn in Suicide Squad,
but if it weren't for the
actress's intense dedication,
that could've been the last time any of us
saw the character on screen. So when it came
time to bring her back for Birds of Prey, she
put in the work to really make it memorable.
The movie was less of a sequel to Suicide Squad
and more of a companion piece exploring Harley's
own offbeat life, and it forced Robbie to
work in multiple roles at once. As one of
the founders of LuckyChap Entertainment, she
also served as one of the movie's producers.
She ultimately went above and beyond,
getting all the pieces together to make
the film a reality and committing to the role
so much that she did most of her own stunts.
Robbie wanted to do as many of her own
action sequences herself as possible,
and she brought that same energy when she played
Harley once more in 2021's The Suicide Squad.
Her biggest scene in that outing involves
gymnastic-level flexibility as she uses her
feet to pick a lock before escaping from a prison
cell, and she did almost all the work on her own.
"She is like a human Swiss Army knife."
After Margot Robbie made the
jump from TV star to movie star,
she didn't stop there. In between Wolf of Wall
Street and Suicide Squad, she was laying the
groundwork for the next phase of her career.
As she explained to Harper's Bazaar in 2018,
"I didn't want to pick up another
script where I was the wife or the
girlfriend — just a catalyst for the
male story line. It was uninspiring."
Her part in Wolf of Wall Street may
have skyrocketed Robbie to fame,
but it wasn't exactly the kind of role she
was keen on playing over and over again.
So she decided to solve that problem of potential
typecasting by starting her own production studio.
LuckyChap Entertainment began operating
in 2014, and it's grown significantly
since then. Not every one of its films have
been smashing successes, but some, like I,
Tonya and Promising Young Woman, have won over
critics, general audiences, and awards groups.
A few years after Wolf of Wall Street,
Robbie starred in another film that was
just as important, if not more so, in the overall
transformation of her career. Released in 2017, I,
Tonya marked a number of firsts for her. It was
the first time that she played a leading role,
and it was also the first time that her
production company, LuckyChap Entertainment,
helped bring a project to life. In many ways,
it was a make-or-break moment for the company.
Written by Steven Rogers and directed by
Craig Gillespie, the biopic follows the life
of figure skater Tonya Harding, so Robbie had
to put in some extra work for this particular
movie by learning how to skate. Ultimately,
the actress and her team struck gold with I,
Tonya. It was a modest hit at the box office and a
major player at the Oscars, with Robbie nominated
for Lead Actress, and her co-star Allison
Janney winning for Best Supporting Actress.
"I was loved… for a minute."
Based on true stories, 2019's Bombshell explores
a culture of sexual harassment that proliferated
at Fox News under CEO Roger Ailes. Several
of the roles are based on actual people,
but Margot Robbie's part of Kayla was a composite
character with multiple real-life inspirations.
Robbie has admitted that Bombshell was something
of a wake-up call for her. As she
told Variety in November 2022,
"I realized that I — as a person with
an established position in the industry,
financially set up and self-sufficient — I didn't
know the definition of sexual
harassment, and that's shocking."
Robbie also told Entertainment Weekly that she
had a tough time getting inside Kayla's head,
and when she was on set, the work
didn't get any easier. As she put it,
"The emotional side was difficult
in a different kind of way."
All of that hard work ultimately paid off, though,
with Bombshell earning Robbie
her second Oscar nomination.
Margot Robbie is a massive fan of director
Quentin Tarantino. Way back before she broke big,
she made a plan to write him a letter when
she felt that she was ready to star in one
of his films. That moment came in 2017,
after she saw her own performance in I,
Tonya. So she finally wrote that letter
that she'd been thinking about for years,
and it just so happened to land in front of
Tarantino as he was beginning to think about
casting for his next movie, 2019's
Once Upon a Time... in Hollywood.
Robbie didn't know it at the time, but several
of Tarantino's friends had already floated her
name for the role of Sharon Tate. And so, he
reached out and invited Robbie to his home,
where she spent hours reading through the script
he'd just finished. By the time she was done,
she was ready to play the role, and he
was more than willing to offer it to her.
"I'm in the movie. I'm Sharon Tate."
As an actor, producer, and business owner,
Margot Robbie doesn't exactly have much
time to herself, but she does have a plan
for what to do when work finally comes to
an end. As she admitted to Vogue in 2023,
"All I want to do is live on a train."
Robbie derives quite a bit of joy in sitting back
and staring out the window while her train rolls
through the countryside. In 2022, she and her
husband Tom Ackerly took a ride on the Orient
Express, which had been a longtime goal of
Robbie's. She even spent the trip watching
the 1974 movie version of Murder on the Orient
Express and seeing how her travels compared.
As it turns out, an obsession with trains
might be a bit of a family trait. Back in 2019,
Robbie took a trip back to her native
Australia to spend some time with her
sister. Rather than relaxing by a pool,
they hopped on board the country's famous
Ghan train, which makes a four-day
trip through the Australian outback.
Margot Robbie has already gotten to work
with some of her biggest Hollywood heroes,
like Martin Scorsese and Quentin
Tarantino. But she hasn't quite
crossed every dream partnership off her wish list.
In a 2022 Vanity Fair profile, she mentioned some
notable directors she'd still like to work with,
including Paul Thomas Anderson, Bong Joon Ho,
and Céline Sciamma. At this point in her career,
it's hard to imagine that Robbie would have
much difficulty getting to work with anyone
else she wants. She's one of the biggest stars
in Hollywood, and as a producer at LuckyChap
Entertainment, she has plenty of say about what
projects she's going to work on next, after all.
Despite the enviable position
she finds herself in today,
Robbie still feels just as excited
about getting to work as she did
during her early days on Australian TV.
As she admitted to Net-a-Porter in 2018,
"I've been on sets for pretty much the last
10 years and I still walk on and think,
'This is soooooooo coooool! Look at
that! That's amazing! Oh my gosh!'"
Margot Robbie might seem like the
perfect actress to play Barbie,
but that decision wasn't always obvious to
her. As she admitted to Vogue in May 2023,
"This is going to sound stupid, but I
really didn't even think about playing
Barbie until years into developing the project."
Robbie's work on the Barbie movie
actually began from a producer's
perspective. She didn't really have much
of a personal history with the Mattel toys,
so it wasn't exactly something she'd
been dreaming of her whole life.
"I think we want, more than anything, everyone to
kind of have the experience they want to have."
Robbie helped get director Greta Gerwig involved
in the project, and the two of them started
brainstorming ideas for who fit their idea of
the character. The first person on that list
was actually Gal Gadot, as they believed that she
embodied "Barbie energy." Ultimately, there ended
up being multiple versions of Barbies in the film,
although Gadot isn't among them. And with Robbie
taking the lead, she fits into the role as well
as Barbie fits into her Dream House. While it
wasn't the plan from the beginning, it definitely
seems like it was always fated to go this way.